this morning on the dish chef David
casares born in Mexico City his mother
was a skilled baker and as children he
and his brother would Hawk her hot fresh
bread on city streets they eventually
took over the business turning it into
one of Mexico's largest baking companies
after a cooking school degree and
collaborations with the world's best
bakers he and his brother Jose opened
their dream project San Antonio's la
panaderia where they bake up their
mother's pan dulce and other creations
at two bustling locations David casseras
good morning welcome to the bit learning
thank you I have to say that ever since
they told us yesterday questions with
tequila baked in that's all I've been
thinking yes of course well you know it
was an accident it was an accident the
first time that I was baking for the
farmers market my brother asked me hey
what you don't make some almond
croissants they are so good yeah so I
was baking at 2:00 a.m. in the morning
but I was looking at my notes and I
realized that the original recipe comes
with rot with the beverage you know and
I had no wrong but I look at the kitchen
and I had a bottle of tequila why I
dropped the bottle of tequila
I didn't say a word next day and guess
what it was a top seller so we have that
what else do we have here listen okay so
we have the tapas so the torta is the
Mexican sandwich but better and this one
was made with kamut which is a nanchang
range so it is very artisan and we have
the the mexican Cubana
Mexican Cuban it's different from the
one that you can find here in the United
States so in Mexico what we use is we
put the best ingredients that we have in
the kitchen ham sausage bacon cheese
everything and then we mix it and I mean
it's pretty awesome fantastic stuff I
want to talk you use you and your
brother yes Ram your mother's the bakery
that your mother started and you were
supplying Walmart you were supplying
Starbucks you had a major operation
going and you decided to walk away from
that well we had a dream and the dream
is that we will live in quality we will
live in the
during the best that we can to our
guests that dream was not possible with
those big brands you know we had to and
we had the dream to build our own bakery
something that was buy our own and you
went to San Antonio to do it why not
stay in Mexico well we thought about
coming here to the US that was our big
dream and we chose San Antonio because
this panic market so we thought it was a
good blend I don't in market you thought
it was yeah yeah exactly and it work
amazing it has been working mixing we
wanted to be adopted rightly seated and
we were right and right now we feel San
Antonio so close to our heart yeah what
so how did you how did you sort of try
to get people's interest when you got
there besides tequila in your question
well I know the story that happened
tonight and I guess that that explains
how people come to us like it was a big
challenge to bake in New York because
we're in San Antonio and we don't have
the equipment here so we asked some
friends and and they borrowed the
equipment and everything so we were able
to bake yeah make to make this table
this morning to make it fresh yeah so
the PR team told me hey David go to bed
early you know stay fresh all those
things night right at 11:00 p.m. I
finish shaping the los beans and my head
Baker stayed overnight to bake but he
gave me a call at 3 a.m. in the morning
and he said David I'm having a problem
with the oven there's some is not our
oven and I having problems so I woke up
with my brother and we went to see
what's going on and we fix it and you
know that's the passion about being a
baker I loved every second of somebody
called me at 3:00 in the morning and
going to the bakery and that's why my
mother taught us she didn't gave me like
a black book with the recipes she taught
me how to embrace being a baker right
and I think that that's what people can
feel it's like having a soul people
cannot see it
but they can feel like the conductor
Zerbinetta talked about the love and and
the passion that's there and it sounds
the same way
you sign our dish okay and as I do let
me ask if you could have this meal with
anyone past or present here would it be
it will be with my mom for sure yes yeah
she passed away like 20 years ago
and she was not able to see all these
things and I think that she will be very
happy she would have liked the tequila
now of course we do that's right chef
David casseras thank you so much thank
you
Laurent David and the dish you can head
to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com